to the sentencing of Wayne cousins this
is the ex-metropolitan police officer
who raped and married murdered Sarah
everard he was decently exposing himself
before that date that is what is being
sentenced for today by Mrs Justice May
today will not affect that whole
lifetime
given the sexual nature of the present
offenses notification is automatic that
too is academic a surcharge order will
apply in the ordinary way
but sentencing also serves as a public
recognition of the fact that offenses
have been committed to note the impact
upon the victim or victims and where
appropriate to Mark with gratitude their
courage and resilience in reporting the
offenses giving statements about what
happened to them and being prepared to
follow through by giving evidence at any
trial
without that persistence and Fortitude
by members of the public who've been
offended against Justice could not
happen
as victims of a sexual offense each of
the women are entitled to anonymity for
their lifetimes I shall refer to them as
a b and c each of them is to be
commended for reporting and following
through
the first of the offenses in time
involved a who was cycling up a narrow
country laying between deal and Dover on
the 13th of November 2020 at around 2 30
in the afternoon
photographs of the lane in question show
that it has a banked Verge up one side
with some Woodland at the top
as a cycled up a man stepped out from
the trees we're just gonna we're just
going to uh step back from the audio of
this feed for the time being just due to
the nature of some of the revelations
that are being heard this is about Wayne
cousins who was exposing himself to
women he'd expose himself three times to
women that is known about before he
kidnapped raped and murdered Sarah
everard this is the sentencing that is
happening place at the moment by Mrs
Justice may but she is giving some of
the details of some of the exposures and
they are rather graphic so we're not
able to bring them to you on daytime TV
he is 50 at Wayne cousins and is already
serving a whole life jail sentence for
her murder and these decent exposure
these flashing incidents took place in
Woodland and also at a fast food
restaurant in Kent and they took place
between November 2020 and February 2021
at the LA incident happening just a few
days before he then went on to kidnap
rape and murder Sarah everard
well he has appeared at the Old Bailey
via video link from where he is being
held in prison at Franklin prison for
this sentencing
opening uh the facts we've heard that he
exposed himself to female cyclist near
Dover in November the 13th 2020 that is
the first charge she is being called
victim a at the time that he did this he
was on duty and was supposed to be
working from home in deal at the time
and also the court was told that that
incident in particular happened on an
isolated narrow rural Lane which ran in
land between deal and Dover and this was
actually just a few miles from where the
defendant took Miss everard after he
kidnapped her and after he'd moved it
from one vehicle to another so it's
clearly an area that he was very
familiar with
um and he's he stepped out of the woods
and exposed himself to a female cyclist
were able to return to the sentencing by
Mrs Justice May
on the 3rd of March 2021
the victim personal statement of a b and
c read in court just now
speak justly of their shock and upset at
this defendant's selfish sexually
aggressive Acts all have spoken of their
sense of freedom and security taken from
them of feeling vulnerable and fearful
for themselves and others going about
their ordinary lives
one woman after discovering who had done
this and what he had gone on to do
speaks of a wholly understandable sense
of survivor's guilt
the fact that no police came to find him
or his black car to question him about
these incidents can only have served to
confirm and strengthen in the
defendant's mind a dangerous belief in
his invincibility in his power sexually
to dominate and abuse women without
being stopped
in arriving at sentence I've had regard
to the sentencing Council guideline for
the offense of exposure the guideline on
totality and the guideline on reduction
in sentence for a guilty plea
the statutory maximum sentence for the
offensive
well due to the extreme language that we
are about to hear from Mrs Justice May
who is sentencing Wayne cousins for
three counts of exposure we are going to
step away from the audio feed at the
moment from the old bayley uh just to
remind you what we're listening to this
is the sentencing of Wayne cousins now
he has already been found guilty and is
already serving a whole life sentence in
jail for the kidnap rape and murder of
Sarah everard but these offer events
that happened before he did this he has
been found guilty already of exposing
himself to a female cyclist and also
exposing himself twice when he went to a
drive-through fast food restaurant to
the women who were there these events
were not investigated by the police
despite the fact that they were all
reported to the police at the time and
indeed in the case of the drive-through
the women who were there what had both
his registration number and his credit
card details which they gave to the
police but they were not investigated
and he went on to kick up rape and
murder Sarah everard let's listen back
into the sentencing
the guilty pleas ended on the 13th of
February I take into account that this
was the first time the defendant was
arraigned on the second indictment
however however it was by no means the
earliest occasion on which he could have
indicated a guilty plea
the defendant is attending via a link
from his prison he's to stay seated
where he is
for the offense against a count two on
indictment number T
2022.0638 the sentence is one of 19
months imprisonment
there will be concurrent sentences of
six months on each of counts two and
three on indictment T
2022-0320 the total sentence is
accordingly one of 19 months as I have
already said
so uh let's just remind you what we are
listening into this is the sentencing of
Wayne cousins for indecent exposure this
is the former police officer uh that
killed Sarah everard before he carried
this out he had exposed himself a number
of times to women and this is what he is
now being tried found guilty of but it's
a sentencing that we are hearing now
from Mrs Justice May because of the
nature of what he did these sexual
exposures that he made to women some of
the content we can't bring you
unfortunately on daytime TV so we are
um dipping the sound when it is
inappropriate to do so
um but the court has heard that he
exposed himself three times that is
known about three times that were
reported to police once to a female
cyclist who was cycling on her own
through a wooded area he was fully naked
when he exposed himself to her and twice
to women working in fast food
restaurants who handed him food and and
saw that he was exposing himself in the
car as they handed over the food now in
the case of of all of these the the lady
on the bike reported it to police and
told other people who were in the woods
at the time also the two fast food
workers reported to police along with
his license plate and his name and
credit cards details
but no action was taken by the police
we've heard Mrs Justice May saying that
these victims felt shock
and his aggressive exposure and the fact
that no police came to find him can only
have served to increase his belief that
his ability to dominate women without
being caught
and now on the first account count a he
has been sentenced to 19 months in
prison then to concurrent sentences of
six months for counts two and three this
is after he admitted these three
incidents of a decent exposure committed
in the months before he kidnapped raped
and murdered Sarah everard worth
reminding that the last exposure was
just a matter of days before he went on
to kidnap rape and murder Sarah everard
and many uh people who who study violent
patterns of behavior have said that
there are links between those who expose
themselves sexually to people who then
tend to go on and commit more serious
violent acts later so we've heard that
Mrs Justice May has sentenced Wayne
cousins to 19 months in prison after his
admission of three incidents of indecent
exposure committed in the months before
he kidnapped raped and murdered Sarah
everod he is serving already a whole
life jail sentence up in franking gel in
the Northeast for her murder but this
will be added to that sentence
so this sentencing now happening at the
Old Bay we're able to bring you some
elements of it live but unfortunately
because of the sexual nature of some of
it we have to step away from the feed
when it is too explicit these incidents
happened not far from where he was based
the incident in the woods when he
exposed himself to a cyclist happened on
an isolated Lane between deal and Dover
and this was only a few miles from where
he took Ms everard having kidnapped her
moving her from one vehicle to another
at the time now the the lady that he
exposed himself then too was really
shocked she saw I met some other women
further in in the wood told them what
had happened went home told her family
and then reported it to the police and
also reported the car that she had seen
which was his car but because she didn't
have a number plate the investigation
stalled at the time but she then
contacted the police again after that
she saw his image after the murder of
Sarah everard and she knew that it was
the same person and they were able to
link the two
he was meant to be working at home at
the time and then the other incidents
were at a drive through fast food
restaurants in Kent the female staff
there after he exposed himself were left
shaken upset and angry now he used his
own credit card to pay for his meal
there and also the auto automatic number
plate recognition service and cell site
data was used to track his car in the
area at the time of the incidents but
this was of course only done
retrospectively after he had murdered
Sarah everard the hearing there has
finished and we are expecting reaction
from the crown prosecution service and
the Metropolitan Police as well many
women's rights campaigners will say that
they have questions to answer about why
these crimes were not investigated when
they had clear evidence that could have
led him to this person carrying out
these crimes and could potentially have
stopped the kidnap rape and murder of
Sarah everard indeed one of the victims
in the court has told the court how she
has real guilt and remorse that had she
not been able to do more to identify him
it could have stopped this pattern of
behavior so we are expecting to get a
response to to what has happened he has
denied other indecent exposure
allegations incidentally but we will
bring you more on the judge's comments
and we will bring you more reaction to
this sentencing at the Old Bailey when
we are able to a little a little later
today
well just remind you former metropolitan
police officer Wayne cousins has been
sentenced to 19 months in prison at the
Old Bailey after admitting three
incidents of indecent exposure committed
in the months before he kidnapped raped
and murdered Sarah everard he has now
been sentenced to 19 months in jail this
is on top of his 50 uh this his whole
life jail sentence for the murder of
Miss everard we can listen to a section
of what Mrs Justice May told him in
sentencing a short while ago
for the offense against a count two on
indictment number T
2022.0638 the sentence is one of 19
months imprisonment
there will be concurrent sentences of
six months on each of counts two and
three on indictment T
2022-0320 the total sentence is
accordingly one of 19 months
as I have already said
to the existing whole of life sentence
from which the defendant will never be
released
well Mrs Justice May talked about the
fact that his pattern of behavior had
continued and the fact that these cases
of indecent exposure had not led to any
police action and she said the fact that
no police came to find you can only have
served to increase your belief in your
ability uh to dominate women sexually
without being caught and she talked
about the victims and how they have felt
about this how they have felt shocked
about the aggressive exposure and and
how one of them has really felt enormous
remorse that had she realized at the
time what this man was capable of and
perhaps if the police had taken more
action at the time it would have meant
that he would have been arrested at the
time
this is important of course because
Wayne cousins who's serving a whole life
sentence for the murder of Miss everard
was a serving match police officer at
this at the time
and he carried out
these offenses that he has been found
guilty for today one of them happened
when he was actually meant to be on duty
he was working from home the other one
happened when he used a credit card in
his own name and would have been aware
that his car would have had its number
plate captured as he went to pay for
fast food at the fast food restaurant
and expose himself to the woman who was
working bare we can now talk to our
corresponder Matthew Thompson who is at
the old bayley for us Matthew Thompson
he had pleaded guilty to these three
charges so he would be expecting um a
relatively Hefty sentence but this would
just be added to his whole life jail
sentence won't it
it will yes so it's 19 months in total
for the three offenses of indecent
exposure that breaks down as 19 months
for the first offense which took place
in Woodlands in Kent in November of 2020
and then a subsequent two sentence
sentences of six months each for the
later incidents which were at the fast
food restaurants in Kent in February of
2020 but all of those sentence says are
going to be served concurrently at the
same time which means a total if you
like of 19 months in prison of course in
some ways that is academic because as
the judge made clear Wayne cousins is
already serving a whole life sentence in
prison an hmp Franklin and County Durham
for the kidnap rape and murder of Sarah
everard in 2021 and so he will die in
prison whatever happens but the judge
was I thought very interesting on
exactly why it was important that he'd
be sentenced for those other crimes even
if it made no practical difference to
the amount of time that he would spend
in prison she said it was first and
foremost important for the
administration of justice for a public
recognition that these crimes took place
but also for some form of restitution
for the victims and as well as she said
to recognize The Bravery of the victims
for coming forward without them without
their actions incoming forward she said
Justice would not be served so for all
those reasons even if it is slightly
academic the judge said it was very
important that he'd be sentenced for
those crimes in terms of The Facts of
what happened it was interesting to see
them set out at some length in terms of
the first incident which the judge
deemed to be the most serious cousins
was in Woodlands in Kent in November
2020 he stepped out as a passing lone
female cyclist was passing by
completely naked and began to pleasure
himself in front of her and she then
reported it to police she did actually
pass his car as she was cycling off but
only had a partial remembrance of his
license plate and so for that reason the
police said they were unable to progress
the investigation any further then what
happened in the February of 2021 was Mr
cousins was using a drive-through at a
fast food restaurant in Kent he exposed
himself to two members of female members
of staff at the fast food restaurant
there is CCTV footage of cousins car
with its license plate in full view also
he used his own credit card to pay for
the food and so the restaurant had a
copy of the receipt with his credit card
number but that first incident on
Valentine's Day on the 14th of February
was not actually reported to police not
at least until two weeks later when he
did the same thing again and again there
was CCTV footage and again he used the
the same credit card so there was
records of that the following day it was
reported to police and the fact that it
was the same credit card as a similar
incident that had happened two weeks
before but nothing was done cousins was
not interviewed or contacted by police
and as we know tragically less than a
week later he went on to commit the rape
kidnap and murder of Sarah everard so
this is if you like cousins potentially
unless new allegations emerge of course
cousin's last day in court
but what attention will now turn to is
the extent to which there may have been
options possibilities for stopping him
at some point had police investigated
for example an incident that took place
in Kent in 2015 when his number plate
was taken had they investigated any of
the incidents in November through to
February 2021
could they have stopped cousins could
they have done enough to at least get
him suspended from his role as a police
officer which as we know tragically he
used to then trick Sarah everard into
getting into his car in fact he arrested
her didn't he so there are many options
potentially for investigating uh what
went wrong in the police investigations
themselves that is all of course the
subject of a home Office inquiry under
Dame uh Angelini which is taking place
as we speak so that is where the
attention will turn we know now of
course as we did even prior to today
that Wayne cousins will spend the rest
of his life in prison but now for
important reasons explained by the judge
he's added to that another sentence of
19 months for several counts of indecent
exposure